J'espère que tu te chie pas dans le pantalon ?
Quoi ?
Tu te chie dessus
J'espère que t'as fini, maintenant
C'est toi ?
T'as chié dans ton putain de pantalon
La première fois que je l'ai rencontré
Jesus m'a dit que mon monde allait devenir beaucoup plus grand
Et nous rencontrions ce monde
Nous vous rencontrions les uns les autres
Ce gros monde nous reviens
De droit
Ceux qui utilisent et prennent
Et tue, Nous y mettrons fin !
Merci majesté !
Pour quoi ?
D'être un mec génial
Tous ce que nous avons gagné
Tout ce que nous avons construit
Tout ce que nous avons surmonté. Tout ce que nous devenons
Peu importe ce qui est à venir,  nous l'avons déja gagné.
Nous sommes prêt !
J'ai combattu depuis la ferme, je ne peux pas arrêter maintenant
Nous avons besoin de gagner, laissez-moi venir avec vous
Je dois te corriger à ce sujet !
Nous avons besoin d'avoir foi en nous
Si nous pouvons nous tenir à cela, c'est tout ce que nous avons
Le futur est à nous !
Le monde est à nous !
Couvrez vous les oreilles !
Fait confiance au roi !
Ca fonctionnera, c'est le plan !
Et celui la, c'est le jour
Ou nous avons commencé à refaire le monde !
Nous ne les avons plus !
Je ne mourrai pas